schools can be kind of Cromwellian
places they can be puritanical they can
be places where it's reading writing and
arithmetic and nothing else and games
are actually quite educational if their
educational when you say okay we're
going to play Monopoly the first half an
hour is taken up by which rules we're
playing by you know and there's a
ridiculous disagreements and the same is
true for physical games I don't know if
you're familiar with Foursquare but it's
one of my favorite recess games what
rules are we playing with the kids could
use up all of their recess time just
negotiating the rules and you know it
sort of seems a little bit silly but
it's it's actually very healthy for
children to know how to negotiate and
navigate if you think about an adult
workplace right and all the internal
politics of who's going to lead the
meeting who gets to speak at the meeting
whose word is worth more I mean office
politics actually is the same thing as
what's going on in Foursquare as they're
negotiating the rules and so having
those social and emotional skills and
giving kids the space and the time for
that is actually very important to
learning and development my eldest son
is a special needs child and was very
delayed in his language he was 3 which
is very unusual one and really didn't
speak very much he kind of became more
verbal after the age of 3 which is very
late in development and I took him to
all sorts of specialists trying to
figure out what was wrong and you know I
got all sorts of very frightening
diagnosis but my husband started playing
chess with my son and it was a huge sigh
of relief because I could tell that
there was a lot going on here even
though he was had very limited verbal a
bill
and one of the beautiful things there
are many beautiful things about chess
but one of the beautiful things about
chess is that it's nonverbal and in
schools teachers tend to valorize verbal
agility so I did very well as a child
because I chat a lot you could be highly
highly intelligent but not have that
level of verbal agility and so one of
the things we have to do in schools is
give different types of children with
different strengths and growth areas
opportunities to learn and be confident
and Excel and so what I love about chess
is not only is it just a beautiful game
and as important as mathematical
thinking its strategic thinking but it
puts language aside and so it gives
children who are less verbal an
opportunity to shine and be confident
and have a level of mastery and so much
of school is about reading and verbal
agility and so you create this kind of
sacred space where a different kind of
intelligence can kind of bubble to the
top
you